si je prends la parole devant vous
aujourd'hui chez un collègue c'est
d'abord pour vous interpeller sur un
sujet qui me tient particulièrement à
coeur
mesdames et messieurs les conseillers
exécutifs
mesdames et messieurs les membres de
l'assemblée de lentilles nique
mesdames et messieurs vous savez
peut-être que je travaille et je ne suis
pas la seule à l'émergence d'une filière
qu'on pourrait qualifier d'orpheline
d'oublier mais aujourd'hui émergentes la
filière cacao
cela pourrait vous surprendre qu'en tant
qu'élu je puisse défendre un dossier que
je prends à travers une structure que je
préside
alors sachez que je ne suis pas rentré
en politique sans conviction et sans
être porteuse rien du tout cela me
semble être le minimum que nous devrions
tous plantés alors là je ne suis pas
juge et partie et vous me permettrez
d'être la partie qui défend la filière
cacao et et vous les juges je vais pas
répondre l'historique tout ce que je
peux dire c'est que même là où nous
mêmes nous ne nous attendions pas je
parle du salon du chocolat de paris et d
international cocoa laddh
nous avons été reconnus parmi les
meilleurs mondiaux et si la qualité
incontestable
nous avons un problème de micro lé c'est
bon
donc je disais que même là où on ne nous
attendait pas au salon du chocolat de
paris et aux international cocoa awards
on a été reconnu parmi les meilleurs
mondiaux et s'il a pondu qualité
incontestable des résultats précédents
fruit d'un travail acharné des
collaboratrices et collaborateurs du
parme n'était pas suffisant alors
ailleurs ou delà des frontières de la
martinique on nous a dit oui votre cacao
votre chocolat fait partie des meilleurs
mondiaux
on se retrouve alors embarqué
aujourd'hui dans cette belle aventure ô
combien passionnante avec un rêve
peut-être mais ne vous méprenez pas nous
ne faisons pas que rêver
le cacao est réellement une alternative
aujourd'hui à la monoculture à
l'utilisation massive de produits
phytopharmaceutiques
c'est un peu une culture qui de par son
histoire pourra nous réconcilier
klein autres alors on se bat oui on se
bat et je ne crains pas de le dire pour
poser des bases solides à l'émergence
d'une filière durable profitable à tous
nous ne sommes pas gourmand vous êtes
les premiers à le dire dans un discours
somme toute
quelque peu contradictoire mais les
faits l'attestent
chaque plénière nous votons ensemble
parce que nous savons le faire de temps
à autre des sommes attribuées à des
associations à des entreprises nous nous
positionnons bref nous prenons des
décisions
malheureusement le dossier concernant la
filière cacao n'avance pas nous
attendons une décision claire au sujet
d'une subvention de 22 mille cinq cents
euros somme assez dérisoires qui doit
être attribué à valga qu il y a là une
urgence réel et je parle d'urgence réel
parce que si on n'a pas cette somme on
sera obligé de licencier à la fin du
mois et célia est juste une erreur
d'écriture sur une convention est ce que
je voulais dire c'est que je n'ai pas
encore atteint l'âge où on ego va
dépasser l'envi de devoir avancer les
choses de mon pays de notre pays
alors vraiment très calmement et de
façon complètement détaché je vous dis
aujourd'hui que si ma seule démission
permettra le déblocage de ce dossier et
la non dissolution de l'association des
producteurs de cacao de martinique
je le ferai en toute humilité pas parce
que je m'avoue ray vaincu de quoi que ce
soit mais simplement parce que lorsqu'on
aime il faut pas voir parfois savoir se
détacher
vous pouvez ne pas avoir envie de moi à
la tête de cette filière je le conçois
mais vous ne pouvez pas si vous êtes
honnête avec vous même trouvé quelques
arguments en sa défaveur
je souhaite réellement que ce cri
dallaire puisse se transformer en
espoirs pour la filière j'espère encore
et encore que la martinique aime ses
enfants
j'y crois en tout cas pour ma part et ne
me verra pas partir je suis là debout
pour elle pour nous parce que j'aime mon
pays parce que je le pente en moins
parce que j'y crois je vous remercie de
m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]